well September marks Suicide Prevention
awareness month and whether you have
struggled with suicide yourself or have
lost a loved one know that you're not
alone well today one CCSD police officer
is opening up about a personal loss in
hopes of preventing another
a year and a month ago I got one of the
worst phone calls
um I could ever get
my brother called to tell me that my
niece his daughter had committed suicide
the night before a heartbreaking phone
call Sergeant Brian Zink with CCSD
police says changed his family forever
14 year old Ellery taking her life for
unknown reasons it's just one of those
devastating things that you never expect
ever happen out of a happy teenage girl
suicide is the second leading cause of
death for youths age 10 to 24 in the
state of Nevada Emma White is with the
state's office of Suicide Prevention and
says while more resources have become
available like the 988 hotline the
pandemic caused an increase in cases we
definitely saw the pandemic increase
certain things like anxiety maybe
isolation because students are in school
and they were using social media Morse
Sergeant zinc says it's all about giving
back he has been a volunteer with the
Special Olympics Nevada and Terrace
Thornton is the executive director he
says Special Olympics recently received
1 million dollars to launch the strong
Minds program it is the way that we help
people with intellectual disabilities
deal with stress Management Mental
Health Management and some of these
students can't even verbalize or they
don't know how to verbalize that they're
in crisis again it comes back to
listening to them just because they say
they're thinking about doing this don't
discount it just because maybe they have
a disability and think well they're just
trying to get attention
well Sergeant zinc tells us almost the
entire CCSD police department has been
certified with CIT which is Crisis
Intervention training now those officers
wear a blue pin on them meaning they
know how to deal with kids teenagers and
adults in crisis and of course if you
want more information about this story
and resources available just frame up
this QR code and click on the pop-up
link it will take you to 8newsnow.com
where